it's like you I meanwhile young people
for example are going to have to pay a
lot more to go to university
particularly poor young people you
haven't enforced the cap on care for the
elderly so that there yet again
pensioners are getting a boost of the
expense of young people and that's not
quite right because we've that we've
delayed the introduction of the cabin to
force it and but on the butt on the is
true that you know one of the sorts of
areas that you can have a big reform
make a lot of savings is in student find
out who don't vote for you unlike
pension as you do on the contrary
actually quite a lot of under-25s voted
conservative as did people right across
the age spectrum but i think i've been
like the majority voted labour and in
the early spectrum a majority voted
conservative but we can go over the
figures if you like but the grids not
about who people vote for and in fact i
think one of the things that we've seen
in this announcement today in the budget
with the national living wage is
actually the government acting in the
long-term interests of the whole country
and with this one nation approach and
actually so you what you're seeing from
the other parties is a much more partial
split approach and not knowing who that
they stand for and so on this central
point about that you're asking about how
do you get the money out part of the
answer is reform so if we say to people
that instead of having grants when you
go to university you take the money as
alone and if and only if you get a good
job paying over 21,000 pounds then you
pay that money back then that is a you
have assigned a good job as one below
the national average but quite a long
way well no 21,000 pounds is a
reasonable level at which to start
paying back you only started a low
amount it increases as you get a better
paid job but the key point is that
there's that i think that is fair on
taxpayers many of whom didn't go to
university as well as fair on people who
do are going through this system that
takes a big saving out I mean did just
take a young person for a family none of
them have been to university before what
was going to be a debt maybe of about
twenty to thirty thousand pounds now
be over 50,000 pounds that's going to be
a disincentive it has to be doesn't it
well but you you the argument was made I
was about to accuse you of making this
arguing you probably did a three or four
years ago when we brought in the nine
thousand pound fees people said this
will put off people especially from the
poorest backgrounds going to universal
that actually never added the opposite i
wanna be epic as physical as the very
porous could get grants now they're
getting loans as well and so they're
going to have a debt actually these
grants weren't going to the only to the
very poorest they were going to about
fifty percent half of students so this
this wasn't a well targeted system and
changing it to loans allows us to make
sure there's more cash in the pocket of
the students and at the same time ensure
they don't pay back until they're in
twenty one thousand but the bigger
picture point is this being able to take
the big decisions like that sort of
reform allows you to make big savings in
some areas and so get away from exactly
the salami slicing as you as you put it
you know so by protecting departments
that we and voters care a lot about like
the NHS like schools like a defense and
national security by protecting those
and by big reforms we're able to make
savings in a way that supports the
services that the public rely on and
after all the goal of this end of the
civil servants who deliver all these
services is to build a country that
works better for working people okay
that's what we're in it for thank you
very much indeed matthew hancock